I would like to introduce
internationally best-selling author and
screenwriter mr. Ernest Cline to the
stage and an up-and-coming filmmaker
that you guys might I really try to
remember his name he's going to do big
things please welcome Steven Spielberg
[Applause]
gentlemen haleh colleagues gentlemen
Steven you but you must have been to
college before you've been in here
before haven't you
you bet you've been here twice before
other microphones twice oh good
excellent Ernest I you and I are exactly
almost exactly the same age your book
was essentially a diary of my life
what can you just talk about what this
means to be here on stage at Hall age
with Steven Spielberg who has directed
your movie wow that's that's a tall
order well like I'm sure a lot of people
in this room I grew up watching this
man's movies and studying them and
they're kind of woven into the fabric of
my DNA I learned to become a storyteller
from this guy and so it's it's been the
most amazing and gratifying experience
of my life it's even can you can you
talk a little bit about the virtual
world that you've created any challenges
that were different than other things
that you had worked on before
well the virtual world was it was
amazing when I read ready player one
when I read Ernie's book it was like the
most amazing flash forward and flash
back at the same time to a decade that I
was very involved in the 1980s but to a
flash forward about a future that I
think is out there awaiting all of us
whether we like it or not and so you
know the creation of a virtual world
took almost two and a half years of
preparation to result in what will
result at the end of March of next year
and when you read the so when you read
the book did you instantly feel
challenged by this I mean do you still
feel challenging to this point in your
career what I mean
what are you ever just wake up and you
go it's Steven Spielberg oh that's a
mirror-like dude does it ever
no I read the book and I said they're
going to need a younger director for
this it was it was really it's more than
you could ever imagine
Ernie's imagination in taking all of us
where you took us and I had no idea at
first how I was as a filmmaker going to
get any of you there but he was the
guide he was the handbook for doing that
excellent please welcome
[Applause]
Zach let's talk just really quickly
let's talk about the job that you guys
had taking this novel and turning into
it because obviously when people read a
book and it's very personal to them and
they they sort of project what they see
what were some of the challenges and how
did you guys go about being able to take
that onto the screen Wow well it was
super easy we just kind of know I think
Stephen would back me up and saying this
was the most complex it's definitely the
most complex movie I've ever worked on
and I think Stephen would might agree
with me there's so much material there's
so much stuff in the book that you can
use that just to find a way to winnow it
down and tell a story that can fit into
a reasonable length so that's not 11
hours that in itself was a challenge but
to be honest with you I thought well
this will never happen we're never going
to be able to make this movie because
yeah we need like Steven Spielberg to
direct it or otherwise we're not gonna
do it
and and to be honest with you when they
told me they were going to send it too
much like oh he's never gonna do it so
yeah that made everything a lot easier
and this event that really helped to get
the only guy who could make this movie
direct the movie yeah tie actually has a
V our production company was correct yes
and what are you working on right now oh
you can't say no I I mean I was obsessed
with virtual reality when when I heard
about this project and then holy [ __ ]
Steven Spielberg's doing a VR movie I
can't wait to see that yeah and so I
mean just to be just to be even involved
in the smallest increment I think would
have been I'd have been so fortunate but
uh you know now here we are at Comic Con
and I'm so happy to be here
that's all you guys yeah
[Applause]
teacher just dying to your tell
everybody and I'm wearing my Elliott yes
yes he is Spielberg and I heard your
program in school named Stephen Tilburg
will he won't he doesn't like to
reference like in a meta way his own
movie so much so I dressed up as sort of
with Back to the Future
shoes I did the whole thing I'm in the
spirit of comic-con and ready player one
I feel so stupid because I just wore a
Jurassic Park patch and I'll be like
he's going to love this and then you're
like in nine characters as I feel I feel
shamed this isn't even it's not even a
real knockout
I took it up yeah yeah that one of us
was like Jurassic Park I'm like it was
first even so it was like through to the
audience there
Olivier we're talking about how mostly
characters of film have a human version
and an avatar so can you talk a little
bit about the the creation of those two
different types of characters yeah it's
really fun I mean these advertiser
sometimes the idealized version of
themselves are a completely different
creation so kind of working with that
with that duality in mind because some
of us in motion capture we had to adopt
different characteristics and different
physicality so to work with that was
really fun and interest in unlike
anything that I've had to do before and
a challenge for us all I would say
coming up everyone so for because this
book came out about six years ago and
were you surprised or you supporting is
this so surreal are you surprised at how
close you are to this vision and is this
the vision that you imagined when you
were feverishly typing away is this what
you saw on your head it's better than
that I you know the whole time I was
writing the book if I assumed it could
never be a movie because of all the
different I kind of wanted to mash up
pop culture and pay tribute to
everything in pop culture that I loved
and I assumed that it could just never
work as a film but that's why I was so
you know gratified when I think really
the only two guys who could have made
this movie came on board Zach's work is
a big influence on me he wrote last
action hero which
one of my favorite films and and kind of
the first movie where a movie fan gets
trapped inside a movie and uses their
movie knowledge you know to survive and
so and I just had the best best
experience with it with the adaptation
but as far as like virtual reality
coming about that's what's amazing to me
about this film this movie is going to
expose so many people to the concept of
virtual reality that I think it's going
to change the speed with which
virtuality is adopted by our
civilization it's really that's the
power of movies and so it's really
exciting the last Christmas was the
first Christmas where you could buy
virtual reality headsets you know
commercially available so it's it's
weird to have this all come about at the
same time I can't imagine why people in
today's day and age would want to escape
actual reality I mean no reason that I
can think of but I guess if the kids
like the VR then can you have any
stories anything that was fun for you
about working on the movie in working
with Steven nah okay good
that was it everyone just yeah hi I love
you guys
haha I know it's awesome I mean if you
turn up to work and Steven Spielberg is
your boss come on everything else is
just gravy after that we have some time
for audience Q&A if you guys want to ask
a couple of questions we have just about
eight minutes or so hey Mike a it was
like hey guys my question is I saw so
the iconic video game stuff and is
sitting to begin the game because I do a
good sinister I hug CineStar yeah I
don't know if Sinistar made it in man
but you could probably see one of the
ostriches from joust in the teaser
exploding and turning into an egg
there's there's so much video game stuff
classic video game stuff hidden in this
movie it's going to make you happy
well nothing stopping you when you watch
the movie from just sitting there and
going I am stood a star like you could
totally just do that Mike good to see
you man hey what's your name my name is
Lou my name is Louise what's question so
my question is for the art they're just
when you when you wrote the book this
was before VR became a very popular
thing
so how does it feel knowing that VR is
pretty much becoming what it almost is
already it's really no we're not there's
a guy right behind him that everybody
wants to hear a question from that guy
off in the back and look at that right
there
so he should go right after but so
should we nobody nobody probably good
I'm sorry what was your question again
oh so pretty much your book was the
forefront from modern day VR so how does
that make you feel that you're pretty
much wrote the blueprint so kind you
know it makes me feel a little bit like
arthur c clarke you know predicting the
satellite before it was actually
invented but when i read ii player 1 i
was standing on the shoulders of a lot
of science fiction giants like william
gibson who wrote Neuromancer and neal
stephenson who wrote Snow Crash so I was
not the first person to envision vers
reality I feel very fortunate though
that I wrote a book kind of predicting
the potential of virtuality right at the
time that was about to come about and
that was the most amazing thing to me
like companies like oculus and HTC vive
they give copies of ready player one out
to all their employees to help inspire
them and show them the potential of
virtual reality so it's just a it's a
it's a huge honor it would be the second
biggest honor of my life
there's a little bit more accurate than
lawn mower man I think also so true I
want to get a question from the guy car
going good the question is when you're
going back to your home planet to you
Davis but the fun's the task is done mr.
Spielberg how many times did you read
the book before you took on the project
and what stood out the most to you that
you said I got to do this will they let
me get away with that please they will
they let me get away with putting some
of my own movies in this movie and and
not be vilified for some kind of grand
active you know grand larceny of vanity
or something like that because so many
of the iconic moments that was chosen by
Ernie
happened in the era of the 80s that I
was very much involved in so you know I
had to leave a lot of myself out or
you know I would have had to defer to
the director but for me the thing that
really made me want to tell the story
more than anything else was the amount
of the kind of world that 2045 44 gives
to people which is so dystopian and so
much you know video people are leaving
the country and all of a sudden virtual
reality gives you a choice gives you
another world you can exist in and you
can do anything in that world anything
you possibly could imagine because there
are haptic suits that haven't come on
the market yet that give you a kind of
feedback that approximates touch
sensuality and pain and so that
interaction between real life and
virtual life by the third act of this
movie is almost non-existent and that in
the book is what made me want to jump
into the movie all right uh what what
exactly got into the brainstorming
behind like like you know from from the
footage you saw like we saw DeLorean and
the Tron cycles like what exactly like
was the inspiration for you to be left I
want this thing and this thing right
next to each other for that scene well a
lot of it's in the book I own a DeLorean
I Drive DeLorean because of this when I
first met Stephen I brought the glove
box lid of my DeLorean to the meeting
and pulled it out and asked him if you
would find it and he did and then I
asked him has anyone have you ever
signed a fluorine before and he said no
I said you know do you know who the only
guy in the world where the Steven
Spielberg signed DeLorean is this dude
that's guy that's why it's so amazing
that it ended up in the film but a lot
of it you know a lot of things that are
maybe major events in in the book will
only be mentioned briefly in the movie
or be in the corner of a frame but all
of its still in the spirit of this in
the book and it was that was what was
one of the most fun parts of the
production for me was having a hearing
Stephen and Zach and other people on the
Catholic come up with ideas of things to
insert in the film and then because it's
Steven a lot of most of them said yes
and so they ended up like how amazing is
that the see the Iron Giant you know oh
[Applause]
the iodine is a real major player in
this story
[Applause]
you